have your costumes and get ready to
boogie down this Halloween season Lego
monsters are running wild at Legoland
California Resort as brick or treat
presents the all-new monster party I
spoke with Jake from Legoland and his
scary friend to get all the spooky
details
it is Brick or treat at Legoland and I
gotta tell you I am so excited about
this Legoland is really for kids of all
ages and I'm joined by Jake from
Legoland and you're already having a
party it looks like already having a
party here at Lakeland California Resort
you know we're entering the fall season
it's one of our favorite holidays here
at Legoland California which is
Halloween with our Bricker treat
presents monster party and already have
one of our favorite monsters our Lego
mummy here with me to have some fun
today but it is a great time for
families to get on and put on those
costumes uh come out have some fun get
some treats see some new entertainment
see some fun characters and create some
great family memories you have a lot
going on for the monster party at
Legoland I I love taking my kids there
there's just there's so much to do for
everyone but now it's like totally
transformed so that you guys are gonna
have what like trade stations all sorts
of good stuff
the moment that you step foot here at
the resort you're gonna see stilt
Walkers you know costume performers Lego
characters all roaming around walking
around for guests to enjoy and all these
all new shows for guests to have fun
with we have the candy coated curse we
have very important monster costume
party uh and then of course we have our
new 4D movie which is the great monster
Chase which takes families on a fun
roller coaster ride as they try to kids
try to sneak their way in to see the
Monster Rock party but the only people
that get to see the Montserrat party are
the are monsters so kids get to get
dressed up and that's where we encourage
families and kids to put on their
costumes come out to the park go get
some treats and have some fun well
speaking of roller coaster your
signature coaster the dragon coaster now
that's being transformed too right
that's being transformed as well our
discard Dragon coaster is becoming a
disco Dragon coaster so you can kind of
Boogie around and have some fun as
you're riding that that fan favorite
ride and then take that Boogie and right
into the park into mini land as well as
in Arkansas Hill and fun town and the
beginning and do some more booking as we
have some fun that evening okay can we
talk about one of my favorite things the
treats what kind of treats are you guys
gonna have we're gonna have treat
stations throughout the entire park some
some sweet treats some Savory food also
for Mom and Dad to enjoy and then you
also have some other treats that guests
to have like commemorative Lego brick as
well as some other cool Lego fun treats
uh for guests to add to their bags as
they walk around the park how do we
become a part of this so what do we do
to get involved in these festivities
so the um trick-or-treat um monster
party is included with Park admission uh
Legoland California is still on a
reservation system so we recommend and
encourage you to go to legoland.com make
your reservation uh for your visit you
can find out all the information about
brick or treat uh the operating hours
for for your trip and then also plan out
your day and see where you want to go
and navigate and enjoy the park but all
that information is on legland.com
I love The Mummy